couple of years ago I had a call from
the deputy director of the National
Cancer Institute and ibaka with a an
amazing proposal she said well we're
spending billions of dollars worth of
taxpayers money on the famous war on
cancer most of this is going to cancer
biologists oncologists geneticists
following the sort of well trodden path
of those very brilliant people have
problem and they've accumulated a vast
vast amount of information here is a
subject about which an enormous amount
is known but unfortunately very
difference understood and so she had
this very bold proposal that maybe
physicists and physical scientists
generally including mathematicians
chemists and so on
might be able to lend a hand not by
giving the cancer biologists a new death
ray but by lending some of the concepts
in say fundamental physics to the
problem of cancer physicists think about
the world in a very particular way they
go about solving problems in a in a
certain manner the whole cultural
physics is really very different from
that of biology so maybe physicists have
got something to contribute now this is
obviously a bold venture but as a
consequence of two or three workshops
exploring that possibility the National
Cancer Institute announced about a year
ago that there would be funding 12
centers around the country and Arizona
State University has one and I'm
principal investigator there about 12
people in my team similar number in the
other centers and it's early days yet
but it's experimental as well as a
theoretical program because I'm
completely new to the field I'm having
to learn very fast my own contribution
is in running workshops brainstorming
workshops questioning the hidden
assumptions that go into our current
folklore understanding of cancer if you
open a textbook or talk to an oncologist
you'll be told all sorts of things about
the nature of cancer stuff which may be
true but it may not be true and it's
always good in science to say well how
do you know
and are you really sure and could there
be an exceptional case and so my job
really sore I call it grandly a cancer
forum it's a runner cancer forum in
which I bring together from time to time
about 20 people will from different
disciplines and will pick a particular
subject the next one is applying
evolutionary mathematics to cancer and
we all will focus on that and we really
try and come up with a totally new way
of thinking and hopefully with a new
research agenda it's it's all we're
about coming up with ideas but we've got
to be able to test those ideas in the
lab or at least with computational
models to see if we can move forward so
what we're aiming for is the big
breakthrough the penicillin moment which
Cancer Research has never had if you
look at the mortality rate from cancer
it's largely unchanged in 40 years
whereas almost all other diseases have
had enormous success and so there hasn't
been that really major breakthrough that
ah now we now we've nailed it type of
moment where the the cancer can be
tackled to make a really dramatic
difference in the mortality rate there
are one or two cancers that have been
cleared of childhood leukemia has been
huge success there but you know it's
it's odds and ends the overall picture
of the major killers breast cancer lung
cancer stomach cancer and so on the the
statistics there are really pretty
dreadful and I think all of us working
in this field feel that if we can make a
contribution by coming up with a
genuinely new idea tackle the problem in
a completely different way then this
could be what we have really waited a
long time for which is that big
breakthrough that is going to maybe half
that mortality rate that's that's my
ambition